la novena la novena cumbre de las
américas convocada desde este lunes 6
hasta el 10 de junio en los ángeles en
eeuu ha puesto sobre la mesa como
también la hablábamos con rosa parejas
de las diferencias y posturas de los
países de nuestro continente en esta
reunión se ven algunas de las tensiones
que complican la relación entre estados
unidos y latinoamérica precisamente
cuando el presidente yo vaya en busca
salvar esta influencia de washington en
nuestra región el presidente mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador suspendió su
participación tras no haber sido
invitados los gobiernos de cuba de
venezuela y nicaragua a los que la
administración estadounidense había
excluido de la cumbre ha excluido mejor
dicho de esta cumbre a quienes acusa
sistemáticamente de vulnerar los
derechos humanos y la democracia para
analizar entonces lo que va a hacer esta
cumbre de las américas quiero saludar en
este momento ha gustado seguir él es
analista político internacional socio de
segre y asociados gustavo gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 como llegan entonces estos
países a esta nueva cumbre de las
américas
buen día bueno desarmados desarmados
porque el hecho de realizar la cumbre de
las américas no es hacer un cumpleaños
donde uno invita a sus amigos y a sus
afectos la cumbre de las américas tiene
como objetivo discutir las cuestiones
que puedan mejorar la vida de quienes
aquí vivimos y es por eso que desde el
punto de vista ideológico es entendible
que de repente bailen manteniéndose un
curso contra las dictaduras y
absolutamente correcto no invita el
cárabo a venezuela guaco va pero para
discutir el futuro de la región es
importante hablar con todos colocar
inclusive aprovechando esta
circunstancia las diferencias que puedan
haber para evitar que esas dictaduras
entran tanto en un tiempo y hubiera sido
una muy buena ocasión para el punto que
eso terminó desarmando la cumbre de las
américas en el efecto que buscaba ahí de
no venir a la región y de alguna manera
la no participación la ausencia de
méxico y de bolivia ciertamente la
intención del gobierno de argentina el
presidente fernández de armar una
contracumbre el mismo momento la
indecisión hasta último momento de la
vid bolsonaro in the moon the file bueno
generaban que podía ser una fiesta
sentados y donde la reunión más que una
cumbre podría ser una reunión de
conocidos finalmente se especula que los
temas deberán ser ampliados porque
siempre se habla de lo mismo
inmigración ilegal narcotráfico
corrupción y la intención es realmente
que políticas de estado se pueden tomar
el nivel regional para mejorar por
ejemplo la cuestión ambiental
indudablemente la cuestión económica la
causa en que se muera la inflación en la
mayoría de los países de la región
incluyendo eeuu mi situación es un poco
más estructurales y no tanto de la
coyuntura
probablemente se mencione indudablemente
se hará el tema de la inversión de luz
en ucrania y la enemistad comercial de
eeuu con china donde la región un poco
tiene que ver pero se aprovechará
seguramente esta situación para poder
hablar decente ahora gustavo con estos
países excluidos se puede tomar que ya
esta cumbre fracasó también como lo
estábamos viendo en revistas de prensa
como lo titulan las editoriales de
varios medios de comunicación
internacionales
además también pues le quiero preguntar
es como ese doble discurso de eeuu con
el caso específico de venezuela
diciéndole pues no lo invito a la
comunidad las américas pero por el otro
lado buscando acercamientos en toda esta
cuestión del petróleo por lo que ocurre
en la guerra en ucrania entonces está
esa doble moral de eeuu que como también
se lee esto
para argentina billetera mata galán y se
aplica también para intereses más
tecnologías bueno obviamente la cuestión
del petróleo para estados unidos no
genera un problema de ambivalencia con
una cuestión ética tratar la
organización la dictadura es más
ecología es una dictadura salvo para la
industria petrolera que nos conviene
esto nos mueve no claramente no es bueno
no me refiero a no ser buenas
inversiones dentro del yo sino no es
buena esta ambivalencia donde el
discurso no se aplica con los hechos
bailén puede tener de alguna manera una
oportunidad histórica o habrían tenido
no la misma una oportuna histórica de
tener en la mesa de negociación o en la
mesa de confrontación ideológica a los
tres presidentes aquí nos acusa
claramente y con mucha razón de
dictadores pero no resuelve las cosas
que no participen de la discusión de
marginarlos además le han dado en el
empoderamiento por ejemplo en este caso
al presidente fernández que sería la voz
cantante de venezuela cuando eso le
puede generar un problema muy grande en
aquí en buenos aires en argentina sobre
todo ahora se habla el técnico quiere
escribir a su ministro de producción en
función en la discusión interna con la
vicepresidente que es una fernández
entonces agregar otro problema a la
discusión no nos favorece y la ausencia
de venezuela le genera automáticamente
en la representatividad a fernández de
venezuela que abre a fernández no guarda
interna o sea todo mal digamos lo
utilizaron ahora con todo este panorama
tan valiente que estábamos hablando
gustavo que tan concluyente y
determinante puede ser esta cumbre de
las américas
depende del grado de
asuntos que se puedan tocar el pendiente
brasileño jair bolsonaro ha dicho
claramente el que no viaje para las
fotos sino para resolver temas
importantes para su país imagino que hay
en él y ver aspectos comerciales
aspectos de medio ambiente
específicamente en relación a la
amazonia y fundamentalmente cuestiones
que ayuden a la apertura económica que
no son los temas centrales por lo menos
hasta ahora no lo han signo de la cumbre
de las américas entonces habrá que
esperar el documento final y en ese
documento final podremos evaluar si esto
central todo en una reunión
absolutamente
por decirlo así administrativa o
burocrática o una cumbre realmente
cristales con problemas y con soluciones
para esos problemas pero eso sólo lo
sabremos a partir del día 10 esas
soluciones usted la puede ver sobre la
mesa digamos que se pueden llegar a
puntos concretos para poder materializar
los luego de esta cumbre
es difícil porque si es una cumbre en lo
que se espera es que haya un consenso en
los participantes y muchos de los países
tienen preocupaciones individuales
eventualmente en busca en eeuu el apoyo
económico para las soluciones de estos
problemas en ese caso no sería necesario
en la cumbre de las américas y sea una
reunión bilateral como se espera va a
tener entre otros bolsonaro con bailén y
entonces en la compra de las américas
puede servir como un microambiente para
generar resoluciones bilaterales de más
no compuesto por la cumbre de las
américas algo que suena bastante confuso
que no me da la sensación de va a
terminar siendo la realidad